goblins everybody's favorite mischievous
big nose too greedy gold hoarding
creatures okay so maybe not everybody's
favorite set of creatures but I like
them and that's why they finally get a
video that and it's almost impossible to
avoid them in modern fantasy because
just like filthy sewer rats they are
absolutely everywhere in books in movies
and in games if there is gold or
treasure then there is probably an ugly
little green man telling you that time
is money friend in this video we'll take
a look at their various origins across
Europe the different types of goblins
and how they're used in today's works of
fiction goblins have existed all around
the world for hundreds of years going by
many different names across Europe that
all sounded very similar to the term
that we use today but differed in the
way that it was spelt the Latin gobble
Ennis and the Greek gobblers are
probably the furthest away from the word
goblin which became the accepted English
term sometime in the 14th century this
in itself had an anglo-norman influence
deriving from the old French word goblin
the term itself was fairly broad but it
often referred to small grotesque
mischievous creatures with a desire for
gold treasure or anything shiny which to
some may just sound like their younger
sibling if one was to come between them
and their gold it would turn this
behavior from impish to outright
malicious one of the most common and
well-known types of goblin is the
Hobgoblin and no we're not talking about
the Spider Man villain although it's
pretty easy to understand why William
Dafoe was cast as the Green Goblin
because he does have that very creepy
Goblin give me your gold or I'll eat
your children kind of face anyway hob
goblins appear in both English and
Scottish folklore but they aren't
exactly the type of goblins that were
used to see in today the word hob at
times was used to describe an elf and
hob goblins were seen as fairy spirits
associated of the hearth or the home may
relative to the brownie only a bit more
unpredictable similar to brownies hob
goblins are found in human dwellings so
taking what their name could mean in
to account they are kind of house-elf
goblins which does sound a lot like
dobby and we know JK rowling was heavily
influenced by British and European
folklore in the case of Dobby in the
households of Harry Potter they are
somewhat of a mix between hob goblins
and brownies in terms of appearance hob
goblins are pretty much for what we
described earlier small hairy little men
that come out during the evening to do
chores around the house when the family
fall asleep very similar to the Slovak
Dom avoid just not as hairy the only
thing they ask for in return is food
well they don't really ask they just
take it as compensation for their
service now I know what some of you may
be thinking where can I find one of
these hairy little men to do chores for
me while I laze about in bed and the
answer is nowhere do your own chores you
lazy little goblins the main difference
between hobgoblins and brownies is that
brownies are quite mild tempered
peaceful creatures whereas hob goblins
are much more douche-baggy they have a
pretty short temper and they love to
play tricks on the family they live with
some were even said to be able to
shape-shift with Shakespeare's character
puck from a Midsummer's Night Dream
being a pretty good example of a
shape-shifting gesture like Hobgoblin
who is more of a troublemaker than
outright evil or dangerous the story of
Robin round cap is one that highlights
this almost a bipolar nature of some
hobgoblins
he was said to haunt sporting tainha
Hall in East Yorkshire round cap would
help the locals husk corn when he felt
like being helpful but when he wanted to
be a menace he'd mix and hide the corn
he'd kick over cans of milk and
generally just make life more difficult
those living in sporting toon Hall
managed to trap him in a well and with
the assistance of the local clergyman
and their prayers they kept him trapped
there for several years luckily there is
an easier way to get rid of unwanted hob
goblins that doesn't involve throwing
him into a well when having a bunch of
clergymen pray for you presenting a
Hobgoblin with a new piece of clothing
is thought to banish them why this works
is where most stories tend to differ
some say that this gift will offend them
and I guess it is somewhat of an insult
to their dress sense whereas others say
that hobgoblins are very proud creatures
who would rather leave your house than
accept a gift so the question of the day
is if a Hobgoblin gets kicked out of its
house and has nowhere to go does that
make them a hobo Goblin looking back at
Dobby in the households once more it
should now make a bit more sense why
they're always in tattered clothing and
why presenting them with a new piece of
clothing is a way of freeing them from
their servitude so I guess you now know
where JK Rowling borrowed this
particular idea from in the work of
talking hobgoblins were drastically
different to say the very least
they were only mentioned once by Gandalf
in The Hobbit but he does say that it
was a name given to orcs who are much
larger than normal which is pretty much
the opposite to what we see in
traditional folklore another very common
type of Goblin from Scottish and English
folklore is known as the red cap a
malevolent and murderous creature who
earned the name due to the cap he wore
being red because it was soaked in the
blood of his victims a very jolly and
pleasant sounding individual I know this
particular goblin had sharp teeth skinny
fingers with razor like talons and eyes
that would glow crimson he had long
untamed hair and carried a pikestaff
with him which we would assume was used
to him pay all those he came across
although it appears his preferred method
of killing those who entered his lair or
territory is by throwing huge stones at
them and then dipping his hat in their
blood the red cap could be chased away
with the words of Scripture but
brandishing a crucifix was a bit more of
a permanent solution causing him to have
vanished into flames leaving behind a
lone large tooth where he stood there
were several others that were similar to
the red cap inhabiting borders and
castles roaming the surrounding land
with nefarious intent although red cap
is often described as a singular entity
there are other stories that use the
term so it could easily be another
subspecies of goblin in Holland in
various other European countries there
is a collect
you know fairytales that feature goblins
which describe them as having a giant
head green eyes and hoofed feet they
were so unpleasant to look at that they
were ordered to live underground and
only come out during the night otherwise
they would be turned into stone these
goblins spent most of their time
resenting and playing tricks on
humankind and even sneaking around in
the dead of night and snatching their
children from their cradle replacing
them with their own this hatred and
disdain grew and grew until one night
they ventured out and ignored the Rising
Sun turning them all into stone fairy
tales featuring goblins were fairly
common especially in countries like
France England Denmark Holland and
Germany there is an argument to be made
about Rumpelstiltskin possibly being a
goblin because of his tricks alike
behavior and overall greedy nature he is
also depicted as wearing a cap that many
goblins wore and sometimes this cap is
red there is a chance this could be
referring to the legend of the red cap
I'll leave a couple fairy tales
featuring goblins on screen for those
who would like to do some further
reading in Germanic folklore their
predominant goblin figure goes by the
name of Al King which is thought to have
come from the Danish meaning elf king
who is described as the king of fairies
which does sound quite confusing
Missy a goblin an elf or a fairy well
all these terms were fairly broad and it
was very common for the terms goblin elf
and fairy to refer to the same set of
creatures normally small creatures that
live underground and have some kind of
magical property some of these magical
powers may be similar to a modern-day
fairy and some may be closer to an evil
or demonic form of magic there were also
those capable of shape-shifting into
small children similar to a changeling
but that is a different creature in
Germany you also have the kobold which
is quite similar but it's a creature I'd
like to mention in its own video in
Spain and Portugal you have the Trask
you which are pranks are like spirits
found in the forest who dress in leaves
to hide from humans
this type of goblin also appears in
Celtic and Roman folklore and is often
described as a short man
they hold in his hands who walks with a
limp and a pointed red hat he mostly
sneaks into houses and moves their stuff
around when angered he breaks things
scarce cattle and throws water all over
the place but similar to hobgoblins if
he's fed and treated well then he'll
help with chores around the house
the Trask you is quite a difficult
goblin to get rid of if you decide to
move house then they'll just follow the
only way to get rid of them is to
challenge them to a task they cannot
complete because of their enormous sense
of pride they will always accept this
challenge this challenge is often a very
simple task such as asking them to
collect grains of rice or carry water in
the palm of their hands because it will
just fall straight through the hole when
they eventually realize they cannot
finish the task given to them they flee
in shame in Greece you have a group of
malevolent goblins known as the Kali
cans arrows which are also found around
the southeast of Europe in countries
like Serbia Bulgaria Albania and Cyprus
these goblins spend most of the year
underground and only come out from
December 25th till the 6th of January
during the Christmas period and their
aim is to make our lives as hellish as
possible whilst on the ground these
menaces soar away at the wild tree
trying to well destroy the world for
some sadistic reason but just as the
tree is about to fall the Christmas
period comes and they turn their
attentions above ground to humans once
their time above ground has come to an
end they return to soaring away at the
world tree but in their absence the tree
has regenerated and this cycle continues
endlessly the calkins Eris have no real
set appearance other than being very
small and as I'm sure you've guessed
very hairy sometimes they have various
different animal parts such as tails and
hoods similar to some other goblins they
were also shown as having eyes that glow
red although their eyesight was
exceptionally poor they mostly fed on
small creatures that they could smell so
during this Christmas period you'd want
to keep your household pets close as a
result of this during the Christmas
period people took several precautions
to keep these disgusting little hairy
men
away from their homes one of the most
popular being leaving a colander outside
the door this works because they can't
count past the number two because they
believe merely saying that third number
will immediately kill them I'm not sure
what kind of sense this makes but it
results in them sitting outside all
night counting the holes in the colander
starting over once they get to that
accursed number three eventually the Sun
rises and they're forced to run away and
hide another method of protection is to
leave one's fireplace burning all night
so they can't use it as a way to enter
without becoming charcoal some also
burned old socks in their fireplace
believe in that the smell would help to
repel any unwanted Christmas guests in
modern fiction the terms elf fairy &
goblin refer to entirely different
creatures but that's not to say we don't
get a large variety of different types
of goblin quite often they're depicted
as a horde of big dum-dums that just
want to be a menace in the Artemis Fowl
book series the goblins are considered
very stupid by the other races but they
do have the ability to conjure fireballs
now this combined with fireproof skin a
serious lack of brain cells and the
inability to get along with the other
races means they are more than just a
slight nuisance the goblins and Harry
Potter are slightly different in terms
of them being sly and calculated but
they still have that stereotypical give
me or your gold vibe to them I mean a
bunch of them working Gringotts Bank
counting gold all day which does seem
like a goblins dream job until someone
actually withdraws their money and you
have to give them the gold they also
have a long history of fighting for
acceptance from the Wizarding World who
saw them as vastly inferior but that is
another story now as we mentioned
earlier in the work of Tolkien goblins
and orcs are essentially the same
species with ox even being considered a
type of goblin normal goblins were very
small whereas hobgoblins are much larger
and orcs were somewhere in between in
The Hobbit movies both as org you and
the great Goblin that big fat dude in
the cave of like 12 chins are both
considered to be goblins but they are
noticeably bigger than the rest so I'm
not sure if that makes them hobgoblins
on
with that said there is a pretty clear
distinction between the two as organ the
goblins of the Misty Mountains have a
much paler complexion and are closer to
humans in stature whereas the goblins
found in the mines of Moria are your
typical angry little green men with
bulbous eyes and a horde or tribal
mentality it is worth mentioning that
orcs and goblins are very tribal
creatures in general the actual color of
a goblin can range anywhere from green
to red and even yellow in some cases but
most people myself included will think
of the color green when goblins are
mentioned anyone who has played some
kind of modern fantasy game has
undoubtedly either played as a goblin or
come across them in some capacity goblin
merchants been amongst my favorite and
some of the most popular if you are
someone who plays a bunch of multiplayer
games then you may have come across the
term loot goblin which is essentially
when a cretinous individual decides they
want all the loot just because they're a
real-life goblin so if you are to take
one thing away from this video then let
that be don't be a loot goblin unless
you plan on giving it all to me
because in that case give me all the
treasure I'm not a goblin in disguise
I promise why would I make a video
exposing my fellow brethren if I was one
they find out will get no gold you want
no gold
nowadays we don't really see a great
deal of friendly or helpful goblins they
tend to border on neutral characters
driven by gold or some kind of angry
horde of henchmen before you meet the
real villain goblins outside of red caps
aren't incredibly strong creatures which
is why in so many stories they're often
seen in large groups making them much
more formidable and it's also why
players will encounter them early on in
a game before they themselves have
accumulated much power if by chance
you've wanted to play a game where the
protagonist is a goblin then I'd highly
recommend Styx master of Shadows I
really enjoyed it and Styx is a very
funny and likeable character to
summarize goblins are pretty complicated
creatures despite how stupid they may
appear at time
they can be pretty harmless house
spirits that for some reason just want
to do chores and eat food they can be
little tricksters who get a rise out of
annoying people oh they can be murderous
creatures who wash their hats in the
blood of those they kill I was about to
say that they come in all shapes and
sizes but they are mostly just very
small creatures that dwell in dark
places I personally really like goblins
because they're a good source of comic
relief in most stories and they also fit
into most stories pretty easily
providing a pretty good balance
somewhere in between good and evil if
you have any thoughts on anything we've
discussed today you or maybe you just
like to share your favorite gobbling
characters with me then please do so in
the comments below as always I've been
your host mythology and fiction
explained reminding you to send me all
of your treasure I want to be the
mountains of gold I'm not a goblin by
the way what did I say about keeping
quiet
I like skill what gold there is no gold
as usual you've ruined the in touch stop
rubbing your grubby little goblin hands
together there is no gold the entire
point of this video was to trick people
into thinking that were not goblins so
they give us the gold but as usual you
couldn't keep your mouth shut for 20
minutes and you've ruined it all go do
the dishes and get in your cage now get
in your cage now hate goblins
you